la culpa es de occidente y los objetivos
rusos de la guerra en Ucrania se
cumplirán paso a paso de esta forma el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin
justificaba su invasión a Ucrania a tres
días de que se cumpla el primer
aniversario de la guerra la
responsabilidad de fomentar el conflicto
ucraniano de su escalada y del creciente
número de víctimas recae por completo en
las élites occidentales el peor
conflicto bélico en Europa desde el fin
de la Segunda Guerra Mundial no solo ha
causado tragedia en Ucrania con miles de
civiles muertos y heridos también en
Rusia la guerra afectado a la población
esposas e hijos lloran a los soldados
rusos movilizados por orden del kremlin
y caídos en Ucrania para Putin el
sufrimiento el pueblo ruso es
responsabilidad de occidente
cada familia de Quienes participaron en
la operación militar especial debe
cuidarse y honrarse
el presidente ruso también envió un
mensaje a los residentes de la región
anexadas en septiembre el año pasado a
quienes consideran ciudadanos rusos
quiero dirigirme en particular a los
habitantes de Doña ex gersón y saporilla
ustedes votaron un referendo sobre Su
futuro Bajo La amenaza de los combates
cerca de sus casas
y nada es más fuerte que su
determinación de estar con su país Rusia
este discurso sobre el estado de la
nación estuvo marcado por un tono
belicista y acusaciones constantes a
occidente de querer acabar con Rusia de
una vez y para siempre pero lo que
prendió las alarmas en occidente fue la
decisión de Putin de suspender la
participación de Rusia en el único
tratado nuclear importante que mantenía
con Estados Unidos el nuevo la
suspensión calificada por el secretario
general de la otan como la
desmantelación completa El control de
armas atómicas en el mundo permitiría a
Rusia ampliar su Arsenal nuclear y eleva
las tensiones entre Washington y Moscú